all right let's go to the next caller
let's go to danielle in san antonio
texas
danielle good morning how are we doing
i'm good how are you dr jay
dude i'm doing good so what's up how can
i help
hey so um i have a kind of a complicated
question but my main goal
is i really really want to cultivate a
relationship with my husband's ex-wife
um there's you know everything
associated with
uh custody there's lots of drama and so
um i just really really want to try and
get to a point where we can have a
relationship
and overlook um you know the last few
years still drama
so where where does your relationship
stand now
um right now it's very very formal very
cordial
and i know that's that's something to
strive for but i really just want
something
authentic something that i'm not scared
of
being vulnerable in some kind of way
with her but um right now i just feel
like everything
you know like we're right in the middle
of a custody battle so everything's
being looked at by the courts everything
has been
you know text messages are being
screenshotted and so i just
want to reach some kind of level where
we are
um authentic in our relationship i'm not
sure if that makes sense yeah absolutely
so number one i want to applaud you i
think what you're doing is noble and i
think what you're doing is holy and i
think what you're doing
is just acting like a grown up so high
five to you all the way to texas
um i i i wish more adults in the world
would act like you're acting
which is i've married a guy who's
got a child with another woman i've
married a woman who's got a child
another guy
that means they're going to be in my
life and the the more peace
i can have relationally the more i can
be on the same page with
their ex the better my life's going to
be the better my new husband's life's
gonna be and the better the life of this
kid's gonna be so high five
to you danielle um here's what i would
recommend right now
you mentioned you're in the middle of a
custody battle yes sir
um we are we're right at the end of it
you know um
it was a very long process but we have
our final hearing in october
and we should get some kind of permanent
um
custody schedule that there won't be any
fighting of
you know well she said we could have
this or he said i could do this kind of
stuff
just something more permanent you know
yeah i think that's really wise to let
the courts weigh in especially when
things are still tense and on fire
so what you're asking to do right now
think of it this way
is your home is on fire and your husband
scooped up one kid and you grab the dog
and some pictures
and on your way out the door you're
talking to your husband about his
favorite recipes
like you know what we should start
eating at home more and probably have a
little bit
safer meat and we should eat a little
more vegetables
and what he's probably going to tell you
is the house is on fire we need to get
out this isn't the moment to have that
conversation
and so think of a custody battle think
of
somebody else a court system deciding
when you can see
the most important relationship in your
life your son or daughter
they're telling you not on these days on
these days and
you're telling somebody else these day
that is a that is a amygdala fire that
is somebody's soul is on fire
and it's not a great time to develop a
deep relationship
what you can do right now is to be
really respectful
really kind all you can control is you
in this situation right
if text messages are being taken out of
context if text messages and emails
electronic communication is being
heard aggressively or frustrating or
angry
then don't send them right don't send
them and wait for the smoke to clear on
this wait for there to be a decision
and that's when a phone call or a text
message
that says we're both going to be
involved in this
child's life we're both going to be
involved in this man's life
and i'd love to have a cordial
relationship with you
for the sake of the child for the sake
of both of our
relationships and just life harmony and
peace
and my hope is that this your husband's
ex will be wise and will accept
that and will say oh thank god i want to
have that relationship too
she might not she may say dude i don't
want anything to do with you you're the
one who broke up my family and ruined
everything and put
everything on you right but i think it's
worth that shot
now just doesn't sound like a good time
as you back out
is she going to be a good mom to your
um i guess you're not going to be an
adoptive i guess you haven't you're not
adopting this child huh so is she going
to be a good mom to this to this
this kid no absolutely i mean
um my husband and i both feel like she
um the child is never in danger there's
there's uh they have a good relationship
um
it was just the issue that the mom was
trying to keep
my husband away from his daughter and so
um i don't know i feel like she's a
really good mom
i don't i don't fear at all for the kids
safety
it's just the relationship between my
husband and her and then her
and i that i really really want to work
on
and strive for more because
you know like i love this little girl so
much and she deserves
to have all three of her parents you
know um
not fighting over petty stuff and i just
i just don't know how to reach
that point and it's just because we're
geographically dislocated so it's not
like i can just you know
go up to where they live and say hey
let's go have breakfast and talk about
it's always through text messages it's
always through phone calls and
um i did try at some point about
six months ago when all of this started
popping off um
to to reach out to her um and she
kind of ignored my text so i don't know
i feel like because i wear my heart
even so i feel like i'm trying too hard
and
i just i'm not getting anything back so
yeah
you might be trying too hard and my
guess is with a custody battle with how
long have you been married to this guy
uh we've been married for two years yeah
so you're still in a new marriage
and you jumped into a blended family now
right so there's a new marriage he's got
a relationship with another woman still
he's got a kid in the house my guess is
you're trying to
control what you can control which is
some of this tension and your way of
controlling tension is so noble and so
good but it's through connection and
relationship which is the right thing
the challenge with connection and with
the relationship is those
those things come they go both ways
right the plug has to fit
into like the cords got to fit into the
plug and the wall right
if it doesn't fit no matter how good
that plug is and how good that extension
cord is
if it doesn't go in the plug there's not
going to be any electricity there so i
can be connection so
what you're trying to do is noble and
good
my guess is you're gonna have to
understand that you chose to marry
somebody who's in the middle of a
custody battle
you chose to marry somebody who's got a
kid by somebody else
all fine but with that comes tension
with that comes learning how to be in
relationship
and different kinds of relationships and
with those things come discomfort come
come frustration come man i wish we
could just sit down and have a
conversation well some people just want
to have a conversation
because they're immature they're upset
they're heartbroken 500 other reasons
so yeah i wouldn't try too hard i would
slow down
exhale focus your energy on your
thoughts and on your actions which
what you can control right now is making
sure your husband's loved
making sure that baby's loved making
sure that
what work you do is excellent and making
sure that when you respond or
communicate with his ex because you have
to you are so respectful
and you are so kind and
you follow the court's orders but you
also follow human orders you just treat
her with dignity
like i know you're doing and then once
the smoke clears on this deal once the
ashes aren't so hot
that's when you reach out and say i'd
love to have a relationship with you be
prepared for her to say
lady i don't like you i don't want you
in my life don't ever
contact me again be prepared for that
because some people are immature and
some people
um can't deal but also be be prepared
for her to say
i'm in i am in we're never going to be
besties
i don't ever want to hug and like you
know go down on the river walk there in
san antonio i don't do that with you
but we are going to be cordial we can be
we can become somewhat friends
and man what a gift good for you
danielle good for you